-Our first guest tonight
is the Emmy-nominated co-creator
of the animated Netflix series
"Big Mouth."
He and John Mulaney co-hos
the very funny "Oh, Hello,
The P'dcast." The P'dcast.
Here is my conversation
with Nick Kroll.
Nick, it is so wonderful
to see you,
and what a cozy quarantine
it seems like you're having.
-Yeah, it's really --
It's really great
to see you, Seth.
I really miss you.
-Yeah, I miss you, too.
And you just look
so comfortable.
And is that a fire
you started yourself?
-Yeah, I, um,
I gathered all the wood,
and then I turned on
the gas thing,
you know, because
it's a gas fire.
But I just wanted to --
[ Sighs ]
I just was very excited
to see you,
and I wanted to set something up
for us that felt intimate
and personal and special,
because it's like --
I just feel like
we haven't really been seein
very much of each other,
and I wanted to make this
mean something.
-Yeah, well, I mean, obviously
I appreciate it.
Nobody's really seeing anybody
so I don't think that you and
seeing each other
is any more or less special.
-I don't know. I feel like
it kind of is, at least for me
Like, you know, 'cause I've been
Zooming with friends and family,
but, like, when you're not abl
to communicate
with someone that you love
and feel really far away fro
and feel very --
both like, obviously
physically very distant
but emotionally
a little distant,
I think you have to, like,
take that extra step
to spice things up and make yo
and your partner feel special.
And so that's kind of
what I wanted to do today.
-Right. Of course, making it
clear to the audience
that we each have
individual partners
that are not each other.
-You are married with children
and I have a girlfriend
who I live with.
And --
But I don't think
that speaks to the partnership
and the feelings that we hav
for each other.
I think we've always known
that we were going
to keep those separate,
um, from the rest of our lives
-Sure. Okay. Well, I mean,
it is nice to see each other
because, you know, even
non-pandemic times,
we do live on opposite coasts,
I had a really -- The last tim
I saw you was wonderful.
We ran into each other
at the Critics' Choice Awards.
-That's right, yeah.
-And it was --
-You guys --
Go ahead. Sorry.
-No, but you presented
our category,
and it was such a delight
to have a friend do that.
-Yeah, I mean, I presented
for Best Late Night Show,
and you guys won.
And for me to be able
to present to you,
someone who I've known for a
long time, a friend and a lover,
to be able to present to you
felt really meaningful.
-Sure.
And again, just to stress,
like, we are lovers
of each other's work.
I love everything you do.
-And I love everything you do.
I love the show.
I'm so proud of everything
you're accomplishing,
especially in the quarantine
I love your sense of humor
your body, your face,
how you make love,
and all of those things.
I love them all.
And, you know, obviously,
you guys won
the Critics' Choice Awards
-Yeah.
-But honestly,
you would have won
the Nick's Choice Award.
-Oh, wow.
-For sexiest host. And I
say this to all of the hosts
-Okay.
-But I mean it with you.
I hit on all
of the late-night hosts.
But it's different with you.
-Thank you.
You and a friend that I think we
both share a love for, as well
obviously -- You've known hi
longer, but -- John Mulaney,
you guys have
what started as a --
How do you even describe
how "Oh, Hello" started?
It started as a sketch,
characters at, like, the mos
alternative comedy room
you could imagine.
Like, the smallest,
thinnest slice of comedy
in the smallest room
then became, among other things,
a Broadway show,
a Netflix special
of that Broadway show,
and now it's its own P'dcast
-Yes, it's
the "Oh, Hello" P'dcast.
And John and I
became friends in college,
and we've been helping
George St. Geegland
and Gil Faizon do "Oh, Hello
first in the little
Black Box Theatre in New York,
then on my sketch show
"Kroll Show,"
then "Oh, Hello, On Br'dway,
and now "Oh, Hello,
The P'dcast."
And we've been helping those two
Upper West Side gentlemen
put all these things together,
and it's been a real joy.
But I remember when John got
hired at "Saturday Night Live,
and the first time I went,
and I saw --
I was like, "Who's that guy?
Who's that over there?"
And John was like,
"Oh, that's Seth Meyers."
And I was like, "Uh, wow.
Like, who is he?
What's his story," you know?
-[ Laughs ]
You were unfamiliar with my work
until you came with John.
-I just was struck by you.
-[ Laughs ]
-And he was like,
"That's Seth Meyers.
He asked you to audition
for the show."
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I didn't put that together."
'Cause I think when I saw yo
in person in that environment,
I saw, like, you were --
You were the head writer.
You were kind of in charge
You had that -- But you ha
such a friendly vibe to you.
It's just like, it was
this real alchemy for me.
And, so, anyway, I'm getting -
I know that I'm supposed
to be here
promoting "Oh, Hello,
The P'dcast,"
but I'm also here to promote
"Snowpiercer" on TNT.
-[ Laughs ]
-They sent me this --
-That's great!
-They sent me this flask.
-No one does -- You know,
people do that so rarely
where they promote
other people's shows.
-Yeah.
-And I do also think
this really speaks to the valu
of sending out swag,
because I feel like
you are now paying it forward.
You got a "Snowpiercer" flask,
and now --
[ Laughs ]
I feel like, you know,
the pandemic is changing the way
we think about a lot of things
and maybe right now,
people are thinking,
"Is it worth sending out
a 'Snowpiercer' flask?"
And it was.
-Well, and here we are, talkin
about "Oh, Hello, The P'dcast"
on Seth Meyers' show,
but we're also getting the wor
out about "Snowpiercer" on TNT
based on the film
by Bong Joon Ho,
who won -- You know what?
I'd love to promote "Parasite,
as well, right now.
-Yeah, why not?
-"Parasite" won the Oscar --
won a number of Oscars.
It's a great film.
You can watch that online.
-Great film.
-But "Snowpiercer's" the film,
great film by Bong Joon Ho
but now also a show on TNT
"Snowpiercer," on TNT.
-Good cast. I think
it has a really good cast.
-It's got a great cast.
Jennifer Connelly's on it,
who's married to Paul Bettany.
-Paul Bettany, the Vision.
He's the Vision
in the Marvel universe.
-He's the Vision.
So I just want to give
a quick shout-out
to the "Avengers" films.
I'd love to promote a little bit
of the "Avengers" films.
-This is so nice, for you
to use your time in quarantine
to promote other people's work
like this.
-Well, I would say
I'm using my time
to promote obviously
the "Avengers" movies,
"Snowpiercer" on TNT,
"Parasite."
But I'm also here to promote
our relationship, Seth.
and...
-Oh, wow. Okay.
-...I want to give you
a dead rose.
-You know what?
Actually, Nick and I are going
to talk off-camera for a second.
We'll be right back
with more Nick Kroll after this.
[ Laughs ]
-I love you.